foreign
21 The Book of Revelation also
Revelation also also I know we haven't
seen the man speaking yet but I'm
already sniffing an overdone evil
preacher in an apocalypse hiding behind
religion to do evil cliche exacerbated
by the fact that out of all the
scripture to put into his sermon he went
with the big book of apocalyptic imagery
written by a man in Exile the Tabernacle
of God hi there viewers a quick note
from one of the TV sins writers here
what is this I wanted to make a joke
about God's Tabernacle sounding rude but
Aaron the narrow hey that's me said it
was just my mind being in the gut
because it was and I should leave it
alone so as Revenge I'm gonna make him
say Tabernacle 10 times Tabernacle
Tabernacle Tabernacle Tabernacle
Tabernacle tabern look I'm not Ron
Burgundy here I have free will and the
point was even if it does sound rude
you're not sinning the show you're fired
also I have no writers I make up all of
this on my own and God shall wipe away
all tears from their eyes
kids roll flag Marshals the ground is
too cold to dig we'll bury your father
in the spring is it cremation a better
option all around they get to have their
memorial and you get to hide the
evidence of all the secret cannibaling
by just giving the family an urn of
Ashes everyone wins
wait how much do we have left look at
the hotel on rations maybe a week having
a conversation about dwindling Food
Supplies out in the open and risking
your subservient flaw quickly
transforming into a riotous mob ah stop
showing me this disgusting bloody wound
I have enough context clues from the
director and editor in this scene
without the makeup Department feeling
the need to flex as well Ellie you ass
why are you torturing this poor man with
dried jerky goodness that he can't
possibly reach what's he gonna do tongue
it into his mouth hope that the rat from
end game nudges it in there pray that it
decomposes and gets absorbed into his
skin
don't tell Joel you're going to be right
back if you plan on hunting you're gonna
give the guy an anxiety attack as a
quick potty break turns into I'll see
you in a few hours because I'm gonna
hike through the woods and kill a deer
well what do you think I don't see
anybody and I'm just gonna assume that
gunshot we heard was Bigfoot cracking a
knuckle medicine like for infections I
understand Ellie needs to specify
antibiotics but in a world where
infected is associated with the fungal
apocalypse I'd be more direct about the
origin of the infection and I'll leave
quite so much room for the
interpretation it's hard to trust
strangers I know but I honestly mean you
know harm but if a stranger says they
honestly mean you no harm then you can
totally trust them and I honestly won't
send this for being something only
sketchy villains say and for what it's
worth there's room for you in our group
if you want you're inviting me to your
hunger Club thanks Ali would be served
with some fava beans and a nice Chianti
at TV sins
summer weird cult thing well you sort of
kind of got me there I am a preacher but
just pretty standard bible stuff yeah
but if that pretty standard bible stuff
is including the Old Testament we're
talking about slavery stoning women for
premarital sex and plenty other
cornerstones that make most cults look
like enthusiastic bloggers this isn't as
reassuring as you think it is David no
such thing as luck no I I believe
everything happens for a reason I'd love
for this to become a four-hour
philosophical Treatise exploring the
concepts of Divine Providence Free Will
determinism and random chance but I
honestly don't think any of you would
want that even if you think you might
I'll just say this if your go-to tenant
is everything happens for a reason you
better be prepared to give account for
some pretty nasty [__] you just hand
waved away it does I can prove it to you
the story David shares is about being
led to Ellie and Joel after they killed
one of his people in his
indistinguishable from luck so no he
can't prove it James lowered the gun and
of course James turns up at the perfect
time to hear this story and be outraged
and at a perfect time to catch Ellie off
guard she didn't kill anybody she has
and he couldn't have possibly known one
way or the other I know you're not with
a group you actually don't know David
for all you know Ellie and Joel were
scavengers for a large group you weren't
even there stop making characters
omniscient just so you can dismiss
possible plot holes I can protect you if
you're trying to get someone to trust
you maybe don't say things kylo Ren
would say oh wait a second you don't
know who that is because the apocalypse
killed the sequels hey maybe there's a
silver lining to this timeline after
Ally gets unbelievably lucky here I know
that injecting a penicillin shot into
the wound sounds logical but I still
feel like Ellie took the old stab in the
dark adage a bit too literally showing
us every disgustingly excruciating
purulent skin piercing second of this
yes let's leave the t-shirt covered in
infected blood over the infected wound
you just risked your life to disinfect
what is it venison just [__] say dear
you're not presenting it to Gordon
Ramsay
big one bringing a dead animal to a
place where people are actively eating
dinner take the damn thing to a side
door and stop swinging your dick around
while everyone's eating
the horse snow melt so the horse has
water eating snow without any other form
of water actually dehydrates you and
forces the body to use more water to
melt the snow and regulate your internal
temperature I know the horse is going to
die in a few minutes anyway but come on
Ellie this man's not already dead he's
dangerous which makes me wonder why you
waited so long to pursue them both
neither Joel is dead and Ellie has no
reason to hang around overnight or
you're giving Joel time to heal instead
of attacking when you know he's weak
also nothing says being careful like
staying grouped together and walking
down the middle of the street I mean to
question your sense of Mercy David we
bring that girl back with us she's just
another mouth to feed it revealing that
you're about to do a thing by starting
your sentence saying you don't intend to
do the thing if we leave her out here
she'll die yeah maybe that's God's will
I will silence you with my silence
because my silence is much more powerful
than your very valid point but really
the answer is that these guys could
easily hunt and kill Ellie but the show
needs to keep her alive so we get the
big baby girl moment at the end I'm not
saying it's not worth it I just want us
to be honest about it
if anybody makes it down here she can
kill whatever you got it let's talk
about Ellie's plan she's leaving Joel
pretty much defenseless while she runs
off to get captured the men don't know
what house they're in so why not
barricade yourselves in hide and buy
time for Joel to wake up even if they do
find you you're missing out on the
perfect opportunity to Home Alone some
Ellie's Galloping away at full speed and
this [__] just so happens to be in
the perfect position to take the horse
out do it
listen ammo has to be scarce for
everyone in the future but especially so
for this isolated cannibal immunity so
as punctuating your intentions with a
rifle shot the best way to use said ammo
you so hungry for vengeance deliver it
judging their bloodlust when the only
reason you're pushing so hard to keep
Ellie alive is so you can make her into
a child bride and or a paratif
Joel not only survives Ellie's first aid
but is also strong enough to stand up
and kill this man after one night's rest
I started worrying you wouldn't wake up
why you're literally gonna eat her why
don't we just start with your name he
really has a lot to learn about buying
time to escape by being nicer to your
captors Timothy
you'll finding the strength to take out
Timothy was so ridiculous the camera
refused to even film it in fact it's so
ridiculous that I can feel grogu
reaching from the Mandalorian into this
series to help Joel out it's okay I
believe him wasting what little strength
you've regained on a blunt force
instrument for murder instead of just
using the knife again
he gets found out because the people
butchers left a [__] ear on the floor
next to the cage do you want ants
because this is how you get ants and
exposed as a cannibal you're an animal
well yes we all are that's sort of the
point yes [__] but you know that's
not what she meant she's fully aware
that not all animals are cannibals just
as we're well aware that you can have a
show set after the apocalypse it doesn't
contain Bible thumping dictators it just
seems to happen a lot but what was I
supposed to do let them starve no but I
feel like we might be skipping the many
many many many many steps between let
them starve and feed them to each other
didn't he take another man's life to
save yours
who is defending you
that helps your argument David Joel's
killing someone to protect a little girl
and what you're doing is killing someone
so you can eat them forgive me if I lean
towards favoring the guy that doesn't
hold Hannibal Lecter as a spiritual
leader you remind me of me you're a
natural leader you're smart loyal you're
getting all that from a fireside chat
and her refusal to share her name yes it
happens to be true but how does he know
that did he get screeners for the first
seven episodes what does cordyceps do is
it evil no it loves not quite sure I've
seen enough evidence thus far to believe
this fungus is capable of love and no I
refuse to include that freely erotic
makeout session in episode 2.
we could do together as strong as we are
no offense David but Vader's joined me
was a little more persuasive
Troy Baker uh thanks for calling me back
listen sorry you lost out on the role of
Joel to Pedro Pascal but but listen we
we still want you in the show and I've
got a really great part for you okay so
check this out you're a cannibal that
gets killed by Ellie with a Cleaver
because your friend was dumb enough to
leave a knife right next to her
unrestrained hand pretty cool right
Troy Ellie why are you wasting time with
the log you've got a room full of
Windows and chairs smash window exit
Escape most fed her teaching these kids
[Music]
wow Ellie threw that log in the one spot
it would catch something on fire talk
about lucky I I mean uh talk about
everything happening for a reason David
seems totally chill with the fact that
this Lodge made of wood is on fire as if
he knows grogu is on his way from
knocking out Timothy to prevent this
fire from spreading I know you're not
infected no one infected fights this
hard to stay alive man this is just an
episode of David making very confident
assessments based on [__] all knowledge
he's one Proclamation short of becoming
the dunning-kruger of post-apocalyptic
cult leaders you don't know what I could
have given you oh I think she knows
exactly what you could have given her
David you made that abundantly and
creepily clear Exodus 22 6 was that
ceiling beam soaked in kerosene
listen it is hard for me to hoop and
cheer at the sight of a 14 year old
brutally bludgeoning a man's face with a
meat cleaver even if said man is a child
seducing cannibal having said that Bella
Ramsay sells this so well I have to
acknowledge the voice inside me that is
currently screaming yeah [__] that
[__] up Ellie turn his face into
pulpy potato dolphin wall
so when David said there's no way out
Ellie the doors are locked even all the
doors are locked other than this fire
escape that Ellie will conveniently find
now that's Danger's past it's lies like
this that give the church a bad rep
David yes yes cannibalism too but no one
likes a liar
no
damn it Joel you just recovered from one
near-death injury so why are you so
eager for Ellie to give you another was
the penicillin high that good it's okay
baby girl
they did it they did the thing oh they
did the thing but also do you made me
want to save the heartfelt reunion for
when you aren't still dangerously close
to the people whose population you've
decreased by half a dozen whose leader
you've killed in whose home is burning
down thanks to you also also are there
no guards in this town that would come
investigate The Gunshot screaming the
building on fire or is the show implying
that grogu killed all of them too
I sensed doubt in there
find your lack of
too much human meat and the very same
goes for Ezekiel which brings us back to
our starting point the nine tenets of
constancy perhaps you could toss me a
Band-Aid or some anti-bacterial cream I
fear it might be gangreness you look
like a robe a wild scrubbed hustling a
robe with a little taste
good nutrition has given you some length
of the bone but you're not more than one
generation from poor wire trash the
atheists go to hell no
how about people who say they are not
religious but they are spiritual
Straight to Hell To The Boiler Room of
hell all the way down hands away the
Baddies